hey everybody it's Mike from orderflows
and welcome back to my channel in this
video I'm going be talking about you
know a question I get asked a lot uh by
Traders that are new to orderflow you
know sort of what are the things that
they should be looking for in the
orderflow um as a beginner now if you've
been enjoying my content you know be
sure to like the video and hit the
Subscribe Button as well as the
notification Bell so that you can be
notified whenever I post a new video all
right so a question I get a lot is um
hey Mike I'm I'm new to orderflow
trading what do you suggest I do
well there's a few things uh when you
get started is um first get a good
charting software that helps you see the
important order flow going through the
market now you know there's there's a
lot of uh debate that goes around uh
with Traders on on what exactly is order
flow don't get caught up in the
semantics of it you know for me there
there's basically uh three ways I look
at it one you have the depth of the
market right the price ladder you know
where prices go up and you know you're
looking at uh you know where the bids
and offers are being placed in the
market as well as the inside Market you
know the current pit in the offer um the
second
is sort of a derivation of that which is
the uh book map um you know or some
people call it a heat map but you know
but the the main software out there is
book map and it's a solid software you
know you're you're tracking uh Market
depth right which is you know sort of an
offshoot of uh the price ladder the
depth of Market as well as the trades
that uh go through now you're you're
really looking at at it on a very
short-term basis with uh the book map
you know almost on a trade bytrade basis
and you know you're sort of looking for
areas of um heavy volume that's trading
you know aggressively as well as um you
know when a Market's coming back towards
a liquidity area um you know where
there's volume in the book you know
resting liquidity and the third type
is the footprint chart right which to me
is is you know what I base my Trading
decisions on
it's
the uh record if you would of the actual
trades that take place and you know what
the difference is in you know say the
footprint over the depth of Market or or
even a bookmap is you know really what
you're focusing on with the footprint is
actual trades people getting into the
market or people getting out of the
market at what price is it trading
aggressively or um
you know how is it being traded on the
bid and the offer right you're looking
at volumes traded on the bid and the
offer and to me the reason why I find
that more important than say a price
letterer now again that is me that I
know traders that trade with a bookmap
are successful I know traders that trade
with a dome and they are successful and
as well as I I know a lot of traders
that trade a footprint and are
successful it's about taking the data
that comes from the market right as
opposed to strictly looking at um a bar
you know a plain Candlestick chart you
know where the market opened here traded
there um this was the high this was the
low and this is where it closed okay
yeah that
that's that's nice you know you do want
to know where the market open and closed
but more importantly you want to know
how the market traded when it got down
to a certain price okay was the volume
heavy was it light or was it just
average right because you know markets
exist
markets were created to facilitate trade
between
um I can't say buyers and sellers but
between you know people that produced a
commodity and people that need to use
the commodity you know for manufacturing
you know they're making um Goods with it
and you know that you know or people
need to take the the commodity and
process it to make food um you know
those in the early days those were you
know the markets right eggs and and
butter and things you know now we have
we still got the Legacy markets um you
know the agricultural products things
like that but now you know there's a
whole slew of products um you know
Financial based products but why is to
me a footprint important is because
you're actually looking at people's
commitments to the market okay somebody
getting into the market has to get out
right they're committed to a position
right and if the position starts moving
away from them they have to make a
decision do they stay in it do they take
more heat or do they get out out okay
and sometimes you know you can see on a
footprint where everybody's getting out
right if a market is selling off
everybody's running for the exit
sometimes um you know or if a Market's
rallying everybody's looking to jump in
on the bandwagon so to me that's why
traded volume is more important as
opposed to Traders intentions which is
what you see in the order book okay now
you know people will throw stones at me
say oh you know you don't know what
you're talking about okay fine you know
that's what makes the market is there's
a difference in opinion as to what
matters to Traders I I just know I mean
I've started um you know back in the 90s
on the trading floor I left the trading
floor when electronic trading you know
the old Globex System project day NX
access started up um to work off the
floor with those system so I I've
watched the depth of market for decades
okay and to me it's nice to see you know
where there's liquidity but at the end
of the day what to me is most important
is how a market trades when it gets to
price so first get good charting
software that helps you see important
order flow going through the market and
you know like I just explained a little
diet tribe there about um the importance
of the footprint and you know I used to
look at another party's footprint you
know years
ago and the problem was it was just like
this it was just a simple footprint bid
ask point of control bid ask volume you
know you got the Deltas on the bottom
okay and that was fine that was basic
but there were certain things that I
would look for in the order flow that I
want to be highlighted to you know and
all this is you could almost think of
this as an Excel spreadsheet with you
know each cell having you know a value
okay
and you know I know some people hate
spreadsheets but you know that sort of
how you got to look at it and if you
could highlight certain things um on
your chart why not okay so I found a
programmer who understood order flow
right who understood footprint chart
more importantly and I said hey you know
this is what I need the software to do
and you know we developed the order FL
Trader software we got a lot of tools on
there and you going to talk about some
of the things that you can look at but
the second thing you're going to want to
do is you're going to focus you know
especially if you're starting out right
you want to focus on a slower moving
Market as opposed to one that moves fast
like M andq NQ or even es or Mees you
know there there's a lot of volatility
now Mees es sorry es moves a lot
differently now than it did 10 years ago
when we're trading 1600 18800 you know
we're trading
6,100 so there's a much more price
movement you know back you know just
really quick here let's just pull up a
chart
um where's my es chart here okay so this
is an e mini chart okay look at this
this one bar itself it's got a range of
you know 6120 this is just right now
6120 A2 to 24 so basically a fourpoint
move
this is a minute chart okay in the old
days that would be something that would
take place over five minutes you know
here we got a bar at 9:00 when after
9:00 you know where it went from 23 and
a half 23 and 3/4 down to 17 you know
that's six almost seven points in one
minute okay so you know markets move and
especially if you're on an mq or n NQ
you know that there's can be a lot of
volatility in those markets and and
trying to especially if you're new to
order now if you're experienced okay you
know es offers a lot of opportunities
Mees same thing M andq and Q but if
you're new right the whole point is if
you're new to order flow focus on
something that moves you know a bit I
say slower but has more methodical moves
that it's a little bit easier for you to
read the order flow okay so I I often
suggest start with interest rates or
currency Futures if you're just starting
out because last thing you want to be
doing is getting into a position in a
volatile market and getting stopped out
2 seconds later because just due to the
inherent volatility of that market and
lastly focus on just one or two things
in the order flow to look at as opposed
to looking at every little Nuance in the
order flow all right and you know our
orderflow Trader we have a lot of tools
in there designed to help the trader
look for certain nuances and sometimes
um you know Traders will get hold of my
software and they will will add every
single thing on here you can see all the
different tools we have accumulation
distribution align point of control buy
and selling tailes Delta breakouts Etc
Delta Tales exhaustion prints you don't
need to add everything on at once right
and and try and decipher it you know
what I suggest to people do is choose
one or two things and go from there and
what are those one or two things well
the first thing I I tell traders to
start with is exhaustion print which is
lack of trading volume at the edge of
the bar the second one is imbalance
reversal which is a crude sign of
absorption or distribution taking place
in a bar it's not total absorption or
Total distribution but it's what's
taking place in that bar right that's
going to give you Clues as to what can
happen next all right so let's just add
those find those two tools exhaustion
print and imbalance
reversal okay
so right here exhaustion print okay so
to enable it you just click exhaustion
print
okay imbalance reversal right here to
enable it click enable imbalance
reversal and you're going to see a bunch
on
here because it's looking for exhaustion
in a bar or a reversal based off of the
imbalance okay and people you know
depending on the market especially like
I just said you know trade a calmer
market like in like a
eurocurrency but the problem is you know
one of the reasons why it's a little bit
calmer is because it doesn't trade as
much volume as say the es I me es trades
a boatload of
volume and volume Wise It's inherently a
lot less you can see you know some of
these volumes you know just not even 150
contracts 146 76 you know 154
144 and if you're looking at an
exhaustion print what you're looking for
is the volume at the edge of a red
candle or the bottom of a green candle
top of a red bottom of a green imbalan
reversal similar thing only you're
looking for or reversal uh
imbalances that signal potential
absorption or distribution taking place
so that would be an imbalance at the
bottom of a selling imbalance at the
bottom of a green candle or um a buying
imbalance at the top of red candle but
again just having that little Nuance by
itself to me isn't important because
especially if you're on a thinner Market
where you get you see here's three
here's two right these are IM these are
exhaustion prints really what you're
going to be looking for right and and
this is why I developed my software CU I
I wanted to be highlighted to these
things um you know as as soon as they
take place is it's not just every time
there's one it's actionable really what
you want to be looking at is when they
take place at swing highs or swing lows
so I'm going to enable the swing filter
on both of them enable swing filter
enable swing filter and again that's
tied to what we call a swing period you
know default is five you can change it
from from 5 to say 10 if you want but
I'll just keep it at five and and just
show you how it looks and it's going to
clean up the chart more because you know
if Again by definition right you're
looking for a reversal and
in an imbalance reversal technically you
want to be looking for
it after a move is taking place and
exhaustion right if you're looking for
exhaustion in the market you're going to
be looking for exhaustion when after a
market has made a move up or down down
right just not anywhere it appears okay
so you can see right here this is the
exhaustion print right the two there you
got a little bit of a sell off there um
just sort of go back there's an
exhaustion print just went up one tick
not much um you know here's at 6:00 in
the morning boom boom you just go back
here here's one at 415 a little swing
High a little swing low that's a nice
move there this is an imbalanced
reversal um you know some
just went a little bit higher here it
went sideways but again if you're
looking at in at exhaustion prints right
which is volume related you want to
stick to the times where there's most
volume you know not at uh midnight you
know you'll be looking during the day
during the US hours ideally you know
here's a nice imbalance reversal right
here right the 24 you see how the
markets start going up when sideways
kept going up there you got an imbalance
reversal now there are certain ways I
like to trade these okay it's not again
just because I have a swing high with a
exhaustion print or a swing low with an
imbalance reversal automatically take it
I like to let the market take me in
right I like to let the next bar start
moving in that direction right this bar
doesn't right here so this is your
exhaustion print this is your next bar
and it just goes inside so what do you
think the chances are of this Market
going down and making a move if you've
got an exhaustion print right you just
had nice move up then you get an
exhaustion print here right so okay
maybe this move's exhausted but then
instead of and again if you think the
move's exhausted it should start going
in the opposite direction if it doesn't
it just goes inside you know that's not
a good sign because it's not making the
move that you're expecting it to do here
next bar starts trading higher that's
exactly what you want to see you don't
want to see it where it just goes inside
it's struggling to make the move cuz if
it's struggling maybe it could just be
someone you know there was you know
possibly somebody who's buying it up
then they want to pause because they
realized they've moved the market quite
a bit so they're going to pause let the
market sort of calm down catch its
breath and then start buying again right
so that's to me that's the importance of
order flow right it it's not about just
having um something happen in the order
flow you got to take it a step further
and put it in Market context okay if
it's a reversal sign in the order
because there's different signs of order
flow some things are meant for momentum
some things are meant for reversals some
can be used you know in multiple
different scenarios so at the end of the
day it's about putting it all in context
all right and again if you are looking
at sort of the depth of Market as
opposed to a footprint
chart what is the Trader's commitment
because you know you've
seen if you've looked at a foot at a
depth of Market long enough you know
that there's sometimes there's big size
and it gets pulled quite often right as
the markets get close to
it when you look at a footprint that's
what actually traded in the market and
to me that's the most important piece of
information that you can that you can do
right that you can use in your trading
as opposed to you know because if the
market is trading here right it's
trading 61 at this High I know there's
100 Lots traded there that's data as
opposed to you know what yeah there was
uh 200 on the offer up here at 63 but if
we get up to 62 that offer gets pulled
and by the time we trade 63 maybe
there's only 50 Lots there okay
well is it important or not well there
was a seller there but he he he he left
right so to me I don't know I just don't
think it's uh it's valid because again I
know that the exchanges right these they
they have market makers and market
makers job is to provide liquidity so me
seeing liquidity at a price away from
the market that's
normal but if I see it Market trades a
price and it does something right it
either trades heavy volume or light
volume
to me that's that matters and watching
more importantly watching how the market
reacts to that volume that actually
trades is important all right everyone
so hopefully you know you got something
useful out of this video especially if
you're a newer Trader to orderflow and
if you did um be sure to uh hit the like
button and again you know if you haven't
already subscribe to the channel thanks
and I'll see you guys later take care